There's that music again. Come close by the pond, little ones — the reeds are tall and the water's warm, and I want to ask you something before the story starts.
Have you ever felt too small to help? Like the big jobs belong to the clever ones, and you'd only get in the way? Hold onto that. The answer is in the story — and it came, of all places, from three frogs and a plan.
Now, this was the first proper-warm morning of spring. The whole creek was waking up — buds on the willow, the water running clear and busy, the air smelling green. And down at the mud edge of the pond, where the reeds grow thick and the frogs have their little corner, the Mudpuppy brothers had called a meeting. A very important meeting. With a stick for a gavel and everything. About the pond.
And it being spring, and them being full of spring, they had decided the pond needed... improving. Mm. I had a feeling about how this would go.
And out from the reeds came the Mudpuppy brothers — Splish, Splash, and Splosh — three frogs and one chorus of confusion. Splish was already standing on a rock, and he announced,
Brothers! The pond is GOOD. But spring is here, and good is not the SAME as improved! So today, we improve the pond! I am in charge of that, because I thought of it first, and standing on a rock!
IMPROVE THE POND! Yes! Splish said it, so it is TRUE now! What does improve mean?
Improve is what the moon does when nobody is watching. It gets quietly better. We must do that, but louder, and where everyone can see.
No, no — improve is simple. Today the pond is a SEVEN. We make it a TEN. Three whole better. That's maths. I'm the leader, so I know maths.
A SEVEN! Who told the pond it was a seven? Was it Shelly? Shelly tells everyone their number. I'm a four. I'm comfortable with four.
It means we MAKE it better. Bigger. Tidier. More... improved-er.
How big? This big? Should I push the pond? I can push the pond. Where do I push it.
No, no. You're both wrong, in the small way. The pond doesn't want bigger. The pond wants... a BELL. A great soft bell that rings when the moon is sad. That is the improvement. I have seen it. In a dream. On a cold rock.
Splosh, we are not hanging a bell on the moon.
Then the moon will simply have to stay sad. Write that down.
I am writing it down! With a stick! In the mud! ...The mud ate the writing. The mud always eats the writing. Should we improve the MUD?
ONE improvement at a time, Splash. We are professionals. We have a plan. We have THREE plans, which is even more professional than one.
I have a fourth plan. It is the bell again. I will keep mentioning the bell until it happens.
And so, little ones, the great Mudpuppy Improvement Plan began. With three frogs. And three completely different plans. All at once.
Plan ONE! We move every pebble to the OTHER side. A tidy pond is an improved pond. Begin!
Moving the pebbles! All of them! Why this one too? It was already nice! Moving it ANYWAY!
I shall move the pebbles... of the SKY. Slowly. With my mind.
And just then, ambling along the top of the bank, came Shelly the tortoise — wise young Shelly — who looked down at the heap of pebbles, and at the frog moving none of them with his mind, and said, slow as ever,
...You've put the tidy pebbles in an untidy pile. That's the opposite of tidy. But you're enjoying it, so. Carry on.
Shelly believes in us! She said carry on! You all heard it!
CARRY ON! That's an order now! Splosh, carry the on! Where do we keep the on?
The on lives where the bell lives. Far away. And a little bit sad.
Splish, I have a worry. If we improve the pond all the way to a TEN, what happens at ELEVEN? Is there an eleven? Are we ready for an eleven?
We cross the eleven when we come to it. That is leadership. Now — to work, brothers! The pond won't improve itself!
Now, the pebble-moving did not go well. By midday the pebbles were in a heap nobody liked, including the pebbles. So Splish stood on his rock again and declared Plan Two.
Plan ONE was a warm-up! Plan TWO! We dig a brand-new channel so the water goes FASTER. Fast water is improved water. Everybody knows that.
FASTER WATER! Where is it going? Does it have somewhere to BE? Should we have asked it first?
The water goes where all things go. Toward the bell. Which is sad. Because we did not hang it.
And down the path, drawn by the splashing the way he's drawn by everything, came Bongo the bear cub, with his usual cheerful crash. He saw the half-dug channel and his whole face lit up.
Ooh, a building project! I got this! I'll help dig! ...Wait. Where's the water supposed to go? ...Okay, maybe I don't got this. But I love it! Keep going!
Bongo loves it! Two friends now! Shelly and Bongo, both cheering! We are the most improved frogs in the world!
And just as the digging got going proper, who should drop in but Zippy the hummingbird, going so fast she was three places at once. She took one look and squeaked,
Okay — okay. Mud-displacement at forty scoops a minute, channel-slope all wrong, water's just gonna pool right back where it started in — yep — there it goes. Plan efficiency: zero point zero. Maybe lower. Can a number be lower than zero? Asking for the pond.
She gave us a NUMBER! We have a number now! Is zero good?
Zero is the BEST number. It's so tidy. Look at it. No corners. Plan Two is a triumph.
That's — that's not what zero — okay. Okay! Heads up though, your channel's about to send all that pooled water right back over your — yep. There it goes. Bye!
The water came BACK! It went all the way around and came BACK! Splish, the water doesn't want to be improved! It wants to be where it WAS!
The water is wise. It returns to the place it loves. Like I shall, one day, return to the bell.
I think the zero is beautiful. I think we should frame the zero. The zero is the only thing we made today, and it is round, like a sad little moon.
Splosh keeps making everything about the moon! Splish, is everything about the moon? Tell me honestly, with a number.
Nothing is about the moon. Focus, brothers. We have failed twice, which means the THIRD time always works. That's how counting goes. Everybody knows that.
And here, little ones, is where the plan fell apart for good — and where, without meaning to, it did the one thing that mattered. Splish climbed his rock one more time, for Plan Three.
Plan THREE! The reeds are too thick! An improved pond has TIDY reeds! We pull the big tangled one — heave — by the old log!
PULLING THE REED! It's stuck! It's REALLY stuck! Splosh, help — put your mind-pebbles down and PULL!
For the bell. I pull for the bell.
There! The tangled reed is GONE! That's improvement, brothers! That's — wait. The pond looks exactly the same. It looks... un-improved. Oh.
And the three of them sat down in the mud, all in a row, and looked at a pond that did not look one bit improved. Quiet, for once. Even Splash didn't have a question.
But here is the thing the frogs could not see, and you can. When they pulled that one tangled reed free, they opened a little pocket of still water behind the old log. The only safe spot left along that whole busy edge. And something small had been looking for exactly that.
It is settled. We are not improvers. We are three frogs who moved some pebbles back to where they came from. The moon stays sad. The end.
But I worked SO hard. My hands are all muddy and I don't even feel improved. I feel small.
...Me too. I stood on the rock and said big things. And nothing got bigger. Maybe the big jobs really do belong to the clever ones. Maybe we're just the splashing.
Now, I had been sitting under the willow the whole time, the way an old friend does, and I came down slow to the mud edge. I didn't tell them they were wrong. I only asked one thing.
Splish... I'm not asking what your plan did. I'm asking — what's living behind the old log now, that wasn't this morning?
Behind the — there's nothing back there but — wait. Splash. Be quiet a second. Is that... a little duck? In the still water? She's... she's pushing reeds into a circle.
She's BUILDING something! A little round home! Right where the tangled reed used to be! We made a HOLE and she put a HOME in it! That's the realest, truest thing we did all day!
She couldn't have built there before. The reed was in the way, and the water was too rough, and nowhere along the whole edge was still enough. We made the one still spot. Without even trying to.
We didn't improve the pond. We... made room. For somebody littler than us. Is — is that allowed? To matter that much, by accident?
I don't feel small anymore. I feel exactly frog-sized. And frog-sized turned out to be the right size for the job.
Mm. It's allowed. God uses small hands for real work all the time, little ones — and most of the time the small hands don't even know it's happening. You didn't make the pond bigger. You made a place. That's a true thing.
So that evening we all sat by the pond — the friends, and three muddy frogs sitting very proud and very still so as not to wake a sleeping duck. And I asked them, what do you think it was, in the end, that did the good?
It wasn't the clever part! We weren't clever ONCE all day! It was the pulling. The small thing we actually finished.
And we didn't even know we were doing it. That's the part I keep turning over. We were busy being wrong, and somewhere in the middle of being wrong, we did a right thing.
Um... I think it means you don't have to be the cleverest to have a place. Even the splashing has a place. Maybe everybody does. Maybe especially the splashing.
I think I learned that being the leader isn't standing on the rock and saying big things. It's pulling the one reed that was actually stuck. The small finished thing beats the big un-started one. Every time.
Mm. There it is. And the Bible has a line about exactly this. Long ago a builder named Zerubbabel was raising something grand, and folks stood around saying the small beginnings weren't worth much. So a prophet named Zechariah wrote them a question, in the book of Zechariah, chapter four, verse ten:
For who hath despised the day of small things?
Which is the old way of asking — who would ever look down on a small beginning? God doesn't measure a helper by how big or clever they are. He just asks what you'll do with the small thing in front of you. Three frogs and one reed turned out to be plenty.
And now, before the frogs take their bow — a fact. From the most certain owl in Shiloh Creek.
Children, gather round. A true fact — and tied, you'll be glad to hear, to our three muddy heroes themselves. Now: a real mudpuppy is not a frog at all. It is a salamander — that's a long, smooth, lizardy little creature with soft skin, not scales. And here is the marvel — it keeps its gills its whole life long.
Gills — those are the feathery red frills behind the head that let a creature breathe underwater. Most young water-things lose theirs and grow up to breathe air. The mudpuppy simply... declines. It keeps the frills. It stays a swimmer forever. Which I find rather grand — that is, worth looking up to — and, frankly, a little stubborn.
It reminds me of the time I attempted to hold my own breath in protest of a draughty branch, and lasted some forty seconds before — Pardon. As I was saying. The mudpuppy keeps its gills for life. Class dismissed.
Today on Mudpuppy Minutes, we will explain... why the moon looks SO big when it sits down low by the hills!
Easy. The moon gets bigger at night because it is TIRED. A tired moon puffs up. Like a frog. Everybody puffs when they're tired.
YES! Tired and puffed! Or — wait — maybe it only LOOKS bigger because it's down near the hills and trees, and our eyes go, ooh, it's right next to that little hill, so it must be HUGE!
Oh no — no. That can't be right, Splash. That's too easy. Eyes don't go ooh. The moon is clearly closer to the hills because that's where it goes to get a drink.
Wait. Is it... is it actually just that our eyes get fooled comparing it to the hills?
...Nah.
Mudpuppies, mudpuppies — we have solved it. The big low moon means the moon is THIRSTY, and the hills are its cup. And that is the end of that.
Now — just so you know it true, little ones: the moon doesn't really swell, and it isn't thirsty. It only looks bigger near the hills because your eyes measure it against the trees and the land — a little trick of seeing. That's the honest truth of it. But don't tell the Mudpuppies. They're so proud just now.
And that, my little ones, is how I remember it — the day three small frogs made room for somebody littler, and the day of small things turned out to be a very good day. Rest easy, now.
See you next time, somewhere in Shiloh Creek.